all right welcome everybody it's a sort
of impromptu
vacation stream i've got some down time
from downtime
so i thought i would stream uh donald
trump is doing an event today
among other events which we'll review to
pander to
latino voters with whom he is struggling
but
not as badly as he was struggling in
2016
interestingly enough so i think there's
going to be a lot of very very
interesting things
i am going to be talking about the
million subscribers
i'll talk about what else is going on
this week but there are no
new podcasts this week i'm very
powerfully on vacation i've it if you
if you had any idea how much i've been
sleeping you would be shocked
you would be shocked um but i've got a
couple of hours where nothing is going
on
i've done so i'm already through i
finished two i didn't
i finished two books that i started
before vacation vacation only started
four days ago
but um i also uh am already a third of
the way through
a very interesting book a brief history
of everyone who ever lit
lived by adam rutherford based on the
first hundred pages i can very much
uh endorse the book for you um
and what else do we have i i am going to
addre people keep talking to me about
what's going on with stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell
ii and i'll talk about
what i know and it's really not that
much
so we're going to be talking about that
a little bit
um i have new polling data i have video
from trump from earlier
and a bunch of different stuff i don't
even know where to start
other than to say uh welcome
oh well maybe we'll just to get this out
of the way because a lot of people don't
care about this
we did hit um 1 million youtube
subscribers so as you can see now
1 million 1 million subscribers and
interestingly enough
we're actually like 5 000 past it
already but i guess once you get to 1
million
it only updates publicly every 10
000 so now it will not change
until we get to one point wait 1.01
million so until we get to 10
000 right past the million it's not
going to update but we're already
halfway there
we're at 1 million 5 000. uh very very
exciting
and i guess i could play so we published
this video recently this is
one million subscribers i also have
another video
called bots how i got one million
subscribers
which is not publishing until tomorrow
our friend kyle
made this one let's listen to just a
little bit of it as people come in
i am contemplating
some possible litigation
around this clip that we're about to see
right we have reached 100 000
subscribers
on youtube the david pakman show
surpassed
the 000 200.000 mark on youtube
400 000 subscribers on
youtube 500 000
subscribers 600 000
subscribers 700 000
subscribers on youtube yesterday as many
of you know but as many of you don't
know
this program is on youtube convalescent
plasma
thank you to our youtube subscribers
who now remember more than 750
800 000 subscribers oh that's
interesting people you know i've act
i recently asked my hairdresser do you
think my hairline is receding
i don't think it is i don't think it is
she thought it wasn't
this is actually very inspirational look
at that
i think that that's the exact same
hairline
um that's the plasma moment i think i'm
doing
very well from the standpoint of
hairline actually now that now that i'm
looking at that
uh mouth size also seems to have stayed
very consistent okay let's continue
though this month on youtube
in september of 2009 we had 711 views
total and we had 721 views
777 views 721 views
and four four subscribers
we had four subscribers i don't mean
that before subscribers
subscribers
we had four subscribers and four
subscribers three of which were probably
uh accounts my mom made okay
hit some really interesting numbers
on youtube we had 30 subscribers those
are the right numbers
this actually isn't crazy it is uh
quite an accomplishment for us i mean
our youtube channel started
so small back in 2009 thanks to your
support
and i'm talking about the trolls as well
i'm thanking the trolls as well
it was alleged that i established
sort of a race against sam cedar to a
million subscribers
i smell bots i smell bots so
look here here it is right now put this
video up look
folks ronald reagan has just informed me
that
david pakman has taken a lead in our
race
to get to a million subscribers
and i am making a personal appeal to you
right now hit the subscribe button okay
so anyway that's like half the video the
full video we'll be publishing tomorrow
on tuesday wait a second no on wednesday
um my spanish language interview is
going to publish
i'm only about seven twelfths
no wait i'm seven pull out a protractor
i'm seven and a half twelfths of the way
through
um subtitling the spanish language
interview
which is going to publish wednesday and
if i just don't get done subtitling it
then we'll push it back a little bit
okay so that's going on
and sam cedar did call me uh
he did if he did concede even though
conceding is only a formality
he did call me to concede the race to 1
million which we didn't actually have
it was fake but he did concede and i'm
lying about that as well
let me say thank you to katie berlin
katie berlin is new member number one
today at joinpacman.com as you can see
above my head
even though the background is different
i bring the bar
above my head with me everywhere i go
because it is really really important
katie berlin is new member number one
today at joinedpakman.com
and i would love for you to sign up as
well
it is also sub timber over on twitch
everything is some i don't even
understand what it is
it's somewhere between 20 and 60 percent
off
depending on various parameters i don't
understand
and certain requirements which i don't
know if i've met
okay if that tells anybody my
familiarity with what september is it is
happening
it is happening but i don't know exactly
what
it is okay other things to play for you
you know i actually like some of what
joe biden's been saying lately
and this was joe biden earlier today
explaining we have four
not good situations going on at once
you know as a nation we face one of the
most difficult moments
in our history in my view right four
historic crises all
at the same time the worst pandemic
in 100 years that's already killed
nearly 200
000 people in county the worst economic
crisis since the great depression
has cost tens of millions of american
jobs
and counting emboldened white supremacy
unseen since the 60s and a reckoning
on race that's long overdue
and undeniable acceleration
of the punishing reality of climate
change
on our planet and our people on the
lives and livelihoods
which i'd like to talk about now
hard to um hard hard to believe
hard to disagree hard to disagree i did
see that
joe rogan uh offered to moderate a
four-hour debate between donald trump
and joe biden
i can't imagine it's actually going to
happen i think that's why donald trump
was able to tweet that he would do it
because i think part of the deal is
that they only participate in debates
actually organized by the commission on
presidential debates so i think it's uh
very very safe to do
uh for donald trump other things going
on here
here is an interesting clip where donald
trump absent any evidence
said don't worry about all the wildfire
stuff because it's going to get cooler
soon and of course he was told that that
is not the science take a look they're
with that science that science is going
to be key
because if we if we ignore that science
and sort of put our head in the sand and
think it's all about vegetation
management
we're not going to succeed together
protecting californians
okay it'll start getting cooler
you just you just watch i wish science
agreed with you
well i don't think science knows
actually
trump knows science doesn't know trump
knows so just
absolutely and completely embarrassing
just a complete and total
uh an utter laughing stock an utter and
total laughing stock every single day
trump knows more than the generals trump
knows more than teachers trump knows
more than doctors trump
trump knows more trump knows more than
anybody he knows more than everybody i
guess we would say
we do have some new polling which we can
look at
um new fox news poll has joe biden plus
five with a likely voter model yougov
has joe biden plus nine
with a likely voter model the hill among
registered voters
has biden plus eight monmouth
biden plus seven we do have that reuters
poll or
rooters like roto-rooter as some people
call it i don't call it that i call it
reuters
has biden plus 12 so it's another plus
12
pole rasmussen which is a known
pole that leans right has by net plus
two
and then the usc poll from uh a few days
ago
has joe biden at plus 10 then the polls
start to get you know a little bit stale
a little more than uh
little more than a week old so we have
that going on
um what else oh i do have a variety of
different
clips here um let's just look at some of
what donald trump has been up to today
you go to austria you go to finland you
go to many different countries and they
don't have
i was talking to a head of a major
country and he said we're a forest
nation we consider ourselves a forest
nation
this was in europe i said that's a
beautiful term he said we have trees
that are far more explosive
he meant explosive in terms of fire have
you guys ever seen an explosive tree
it's actually
they call them trojan trees you think
it's just a normal tree it's actually a
bomb it goes off
we have trees that are far more
explosive than they have in california
and we don't have any problem because we
manage
our forest so we have to do that in
california too so i'll go do this and
we'll see
a little while thank you okay so unclear
exactly what donald trump is on there
after a short period of time about 18
months they've become very dry they've
become
really like a matchstick and they get up
you know there's no more water pouring
through
and they become very very uh they just
explode
they can explode also leaves when you
have years of leaves
dried leaves on the ground it just sets
it up it's really a fuel for a fire
i actually have installed the sprinkler
system above my
urban garden in boston not just to water
the plants but because my tomatoes could
explode
and i don't want my house damaged i
don't want my neighbor's houses managed
it could all get
really really really really bad let's
look at one more here is donald trump i
guess mispronouncing oregon
and insisting that it's just a matter of
poor forest management not extreme heat
and dryness obviously forest management
in california is very important
and now it extends to washington and
extends also to oregon
there has to be good strong forest
management which i've been talking about
for three years
with the state so hopefully they'll
start doing that in the meantime we're
helping them up
uh out in a very big way we have the
best people in the world doing this we
have all of our people from fema we have
law enforcement here
we have the uh they're bringing in cops
to shoot the fires
um i actually made i brought some of my
uh
backyard tomatoes on vacation here to uh
to martha's vineyard
and this morning i tried to make a
tomato omelet the tomatoes exploded
almost took an eye out and
uh this is not this is not a time you
want to be going to an ophthalmologist
particularly if the ophthalmologist is
rand paul so i got to be really really
careful
with those exploding tomatoes because
that could get
really really really ugly and bad
thank you to eddie liedbeck who's new
member number two today
and charles lehmann or some people say
it lemon
char i say lemon who are new members
number two
and three today um let me get to super
chats okay
i absolutely must get to some of the
super chats that have been coming in
chaka seki says blotus hosts
kovacella in reno with a wild stampede
of death cultists what's next
fear and gloating in las vegas well said
captain flanks says if you die from the
flu it's a flu death
but if you die of covid it was just your
pre-existing condition
and covet is a hoax congratulations on
one million thank you
dan stupka says i need your destiny
department
take i'm gonna get to that let me let me
run through the super chats and then
i'll talk about
steven kenneth destiny
you guys know who i'm talking about milo
avila
says what degree should i get to become
a stable genius congrats on 1 million
player 2 says we love you we love you we
love you trump chant
matty ice says david i hope your
vacation is very strongly and powerfully
full of tremendous elements of
vacationing it
is chakuseki says this is all super chat
by the way feel free to send one in
congrats david plosman on 1 million bot
subs
time to crack open a fresh bottle of
carbonated plasma
yeah i run my plasma through double
osmosis
reverse double osmosis emily maiden says
so happy you're streaming i had a deepak
withdrawal
freedom cleaner says david just letting
you know your video from today links to
a video from july yeah we're on vacation
so we're running reruns thank you
james says congrats on one million david
your videos and streams
keep me going through nursing school
right now
thank you chris says
hope you got the salzburg picks
gordon reed says do all presidents have
to play golf they don't have to no but
they choose to
congratulations on one million jane
says bravo javi says why do you think
biden is struggling with latinos
i don't know the answer to that i'm
gonna i'm going to put together a story
about that for next week when i'm back
in the studio
uh that's gastly says congratulations on
one million do you really use
blinkist and can i i really use blinkist
and you can really use it as well yes
uh johann cardell says
um keep doing the good work and i want
to compliment your way of conveying
important stuff
alex says congrats david 1 million bots
sinful solutions says congratulations
david on 1 million very powerful
g is congratulating on a million joel
sends me a link about my future
interview with a uyghur
activist thank you joel i will check
that out okay and then let me just do
twitch thank yous
before i get to the stephen kenneth
thing
thank you to the following people r
luxton has grabbed the prime
subscription
k.a dogen little chimp hoverboy
10 gig nick succubu
succubu perturbo shisa lion dog
quakes dr allison is in with a
subscription
sam will captain clumsy
matrobe billy nedwell okay very good so
a lot of different people signing up
so let me let me talk briefly about the
situation with
uh with with destiny okay so
um from what i gather and i've not
spoken to stephen for a little bit he's
i believe he's still in europe and the
time zones have not really worked
very well for us stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii
is an internet streamer uh who does
games and politics i think
and he's a friend of mine and from what
i understand he recently made some
comments
about the kenosha shooter which i don't
even want to repeat
honestly because it seems like such a
tinderbox that i don't even know if i'm
at risk of of uh
of sanctions if i talk about it but they
were comments that many on the left
didn't agree
agree with but sporadically some people
did agree with
from what i gather he has been
de-partnered
by twitch because those
comments again this is if i understand
correctly
those comments incited violence or could
have been inciting violence if i'm wrong
somebody please tell me and then i got a
bunch of messages from people saying
david you've got to do a wellness check
on stephen kenneth because he seems
unwell
i saw things posted on my subreddit and
all of this different
stuff so the the truth is
i don't know all of the details someone
told me that a guy named
vaush was involved in the kenneth stuff
i i have no idea
all i can say are the following things
based on what i know right now
um i am uh unsure
about what's going on with stephen
personally people saying
you know david something's you got to
reach out i don't know what's going on
last time i spoke to him
things seemed relatively okay um
i've made my view clear about the
kenosha shooting
and in terms of you know all of these
battles that are going on i saw a post
on my subreddit about people are
abandoning stephen kenneth and coming to
me
then others saying no the fact that
i've not denounced stephen kenneth is
evidence that people should abandon me
as well
because clearly i must agree with
stephen kenneth it's like guys
you know uh for i don't know
the full list of topics on which stephen
and i disagree
i can't think of anybody where i have
100 agreement on
but you know there's a community here
there's a left media community
and everybody has different views and
there's uh
you know very left socialists actual
socialists they're center-left people
there's centrists who don't vote for
republicans because they think
republicans are idiots
there's all this different stuff and it
doesn't mean that i need to go around
denouncing people
okay so in any case i look forward to
having a conversation with stephen about
it at some point
i don't know if it will work out during
this week because as many of you know
i'm just kind of popping in and randomly
streaming at certain points in time
and we're going to see um you know next
week maybe
when he's back on normal us time zones
we can uh get together but you know i'm
seeing things about the left cancelled
destiny
i don't know who that would be who
canceled him i'm not i'm not really sure
i fully understand any of it but
i am not uh avoiding the conversation
with stephen it just hasn't happened
it just hasn't happened yet i'm glad to
talk to him anytime any any time
um i see some other congrats coming in
for one million subscribers
chris matt says i've been watching five
years congratulations
joel says that my electrolyte commercial
makes him think of the movie idiocracy
that's interesting so there's a lot
a lot going on here i also want to say
thanks to robin
espy as well as janae
stansberry who whoa where'd we get that
who are new members number four and five
at uh joinpakman.com
and peop i got a bunch of messages from
people saying
what's next from the standpoint of
subscribers just
two million i guess or one you know 1.1
million is the next
milestone and we are going to uh we're
going to keep the pressure up we're
actually already
at 1.005
and pushing for uh 1.01 the number
you know it's like 1 million has such a
ring to it
1.01 is like okay give me give me a
break dude
but uh we're going to keep pushing for
it we're going to keep pushing for it
kjv oh i'm sorry no waffles says
congrats david you're a great warrior
they say you're one of the greatest
warriors that seder guy
he's a disgrace he's spying on you i
think some of these like music and game
streamers have done it
way way faster than i have um
oh there's some buffering going on yeah
i can't control that
my internet connection is not perfect
here
it's not a perfect connection so um
you know i'm going to do what i can as
far as as far as the connection goes but
please do refresh
um if need be okay a couple other clips
that i did want to look at
um okay not this one
what were the other clips hold on i'm
gonna find them here
not this oh yeah check this out this
this is i mean
this is just vile some say call us
latino
others say call us hispanic others say
call us whatever the hell you want
we love you we love you
it's real really really weird that was
at last night's corona rally
it's too violent wow this is like really
quiet hold on
just don't know how violent the american
people are do they
they never quite figured that out okay
there were some really weird moments
yesterday
um there was one where he seemed to be
encouraging violence ah here it is okay
this is the main clip that i wanted to
play for you guys
this is trump again appearing to endorse
violence let me use volume master and
see if we can get a little more volume
for you
and uh they immediately raised their
hands and the seattle police who by the
way could do a great job if they were
led to do their job but they're not and
uh
and as you know in portland the other
day we had to send in to u.s marshals
a man who's a bad guy bad guy shot
somebody right in the middle of the
street
who they say was a very fine young man
shot him killed him
what god just shot him like it was on
television
two and a half days nothing happened i
said what's going on we sent in the u.s
marshals
it was taken care of in 15 minutes okay
so i don't know what the hell is going
on and then again this i actually want
to talk a little bit about
donald trump here again suggesting this
whole thing of maybe serving a third
term
um i have a few thoughts on this here
with you in henderson thousands of loyal
hard-working great american patriots
and 51 days from now we're going to win
nevada
and we're going to win four more years
and after we win four more years we'll
ask for maybe another four or so
so at this point i'm curious to hear
what you guys think
i think that that's just straight up
trolling um
i don't think that that uh i don't even
know that we really need
it's like let's just remove the guy you
know and i do have a fear
that if donald trump does win another
four years
it's not just going to be about trump
gets four more years and the destruction
he's able to do during those four years
i think that it significantly increases
the chances that the republican party
goes directly into one of his kids as
the nominee
and that's really scary because you know
it's very easy to say now
there's no way in hell the republican
party goes with one of his kids
they went with trump they went with
trump and so i would be
very very concerned about that but as
far as this another four years thing
i think it's essentially trolling and
trump is just trying to agitate i don't
know that we should react to it very
much
um a few other super chats that i want
to get to as we wait for donald trump to
do a campaign event pandering to latino
voters joshua davies says
i strongly dislike trump but to be fair
eucalyptus trees
common in california do explode in fires
but it's difficult for them to grow in
oregon
okay austin magiwick says if you can
also try to reach out and talk to vaush
socialist youtube streamer that would be
poggers
uh okay that's something i can i can
look into
uvian says you get trashed regularly
by that kid on the progressive voice he
just trashed you for a million views
i think the infighting is silly what are
your thoughts i have no idea yeah i
don't um i mean as you guys know i don't
uh
really watch too much like left tube
content
but that's funny um i mean listen i
don't know what he's
saying but um
if people don't like me that's fine if
they don't like if i'm too left or too
right for them you know every day i get
uh we we at this point we get about 5
000 messages a day
across that that includes you know
twitter
reddit facebook youtube comments emails
all of this different stuff
and of the 5 000 every day there's
dozens that say i'm a centrist shill
i'm not really a progressive and there's
dozens that say i'm a far-left communist
marxist
and of course as you all know i'm just a
northern european social democrat
i'm not northern european i just mean
i'm in sort of that that political
mindset but you know one of the things i
would say
is um
if there if there are people who are
focused focusing instead of
issues on just attacking other left
channels i do think that it is a waste
of time from a practical standpoint and
you guys know that there's a lot of
grifters on the left
and right but you know i'm concerned
about the ones on the left
who um instead of really like generating
ideas and content
and putting out uh um
putting out their perspective there's a
lot of just stupid infighting
and uh i i would i would caution people
away from that i don't think it's useful
and you know the truth is again i don't
know specifically what people are
referring to here but
there's also a lot of jealousy in this
community which is why you know with our
million subscriber video
which was just congratulations from a
lot of different people and you know we
talked to sam cedar in this video jenk
yuger sent the clip
aryan foster former nfl running back who
has a great show
anthony mellon fantano we heard from
benjamin dixon
uh nomi kant stand former producer louis
you know all these
great people hassan [ __ ] cresson
destiny [ __ ] the second
levy rosman from the chess community
we've heard from
farron cousins and uh attorney mike pap
antonio who else did we hear from
we heard from stephen kenneth as you can
see you know all these different people
um so what so what you know i i've
deliberately
got people who are not
basing their relationships with me off
of we agree
off of whether we agree on every issue
that's stupid
it's a waste of time just what are we
doing you know
uh in the long run we're all dead are we
really going to waste our time with this
stuff
anyway let's continue i i you know
i'm thrilled that we're at a million
youtube subscribers and i'm excited for
other people to get there as well
other than the young turks who got there
before me even if we don't get
um even if we don't agree on every
single issue period
end of story dunzo okay my friends
that's i think all we're gonna do in
terms of uh in terms of that negativity
okay other super chats a lot of
congratulations coming in about the 1
million subscribers
um what else
okay let me get away from super chats
just briefly
um and get to a couple of other things
that i had for you uh
okay hold on and in fact i should pull
them up
so that i don't oh okay
the trajectory on coronavirus and the
vaccine and the anti-vac stuff so let me
talk about this a little bit
i mentioned as an aside early last week
when i reviewed kamala harris's
interview with cnn
where kamala harris was asked about when
the vac
you know trump is looking like he's
going to announce a vaccine in october
early november
whatever okay do you trust it and kamala
harris i pointed out at the time
did a really good job of couching her
skepticism of trump
as a completely separate thing from
being anti-vaxxed
because joe biden is not anti-vaxx
kamala harris is not anti-vaxx in fact
during the campaign in 2016 it was
donald trump who was talking about
healthy kid gets injected with a vaccine
and comes out autistic and all of this
crazy stuff
to the point where even ben carson had
to sort of correct him during the debate
but i said at the time even though
kamala harris is saying
i'm not against vaccines i just don't
take trump's word on anything right if
trump said two plus two equals five i
would want verification
my word's not hers even though she said
that
it was clear that the trumpian right was
going to accuse
kamala harris and joe biden of being
anti-vaxx and they spent the last week
doing it donald trump at multiple
rallies now has said
she's going anti-vaxx they're against
vaccines
of course that's not the case and i
think it's important to clarify
that at this point we don't need to
listen to trump's fda and trump cdc
to know if the vaccine is safe if it
happens to be the oxford vaccine
a lot of the vaccines are being either
developed
or certainly tested to be approved in
multiple countries
we're lucky enough that we're in a
position where we don't have to
adjudicate okay we can't trust trump
but can we trust his cdc can we trust
his fda
because european health agencies asian
healthy
all these different health agencies are
going to be presumably approving
or not approving that exact same vaccine
so i wouldn't even think about it from
that standpoint
uh it's i just wouldn't take trump's
word or trump's agency's word but we
don't have to because we'll hear from
the uk
does the nhs say this vaccine is ready
to go
great that that will give us a lot of
the information we need
don't allow yourself to be drawn into
a um a false debate
over whether harris and biden are now
anti-vaxx it's idiotic
uh it's as idiotic as a lot of the
intra-left infighting
that we've been talking about okay um
other people coming in with messages and
a variety of different things
um chakuseki says glad trump was
bragging tapiro
about ordering an extrajudicial hit
squad on a u.s
citizen on u.s soil i'm guessing he's
prepping the drones
too owen carpenter says any thoughts on
trump wanting a rogan moderated debate i
addressed that at the top of the stream
so i don't want to duplicate that right
now
we are standing by for a donald trump
originally scheduled for five i think
now rescheduled for
six let's see trump latino live let's
see what we find here
if we have any other streams ready to go
um see if we filter by live
here so my oh my stream is at the top
that's beautiful
that's a beautiful thing um
okay but we're still standing by for us
let's see fox news
fox news trump live
uh okay well we'll just keep waiting
for uh some of these other streams to go
live this is the official i guess
trump to the extent that there is any
kind of official stream
i think that that is very likely it uh
oh
okay let me very briefly just
take 30 seconds to say i would love it
if you grabbed a subscription on my
website
that's it that's the whole pitch we are
mostly funded by individual members who
grab a subscription
if you hate me if you don't like illegal
discounts
if you don't like immoral discounts
don't grab a membership
if you're down to your last couple of
bucks if you're in a financial hardship
don't grab a membership we continue to
produce all of the content
other than the bonus show for free for
everybody but
if you sort of like me or at least think
what i'm doing is valuable
or you have a dollar 83 a month to spare
grab a membership at joinpacman.com
everything we do staff salaries staff
benefits
all of this different stuff it's it's
primarily funded by those
subscriptions there's a coupon code
right above my head that coupon code is
20 20 now that's 66 percent off
yes check local laws about whether such
a large discount is
allowed where you live there are states
where you can marry your first cousin
and that discount is illegal think about
how crazy that is
cousin marriage fine 66
off not okay that's nuts okay but
i will do my best to thank everybody who
signs up at joinpakman.com
and one such person who did that is
brittany blockman
brittany blockman who is new member
number
six today we have a very modest goal
very very modest goal of 25
new members and i invite you
to grab one of those memberships at
joinedpakman.com there are only 13
memberships available we might run out
that's uh that's a sad reality we might
run out okay let's listen to just a
little bit of donald trump's remarks
earlier today
we're still waiting for his campaign
remarks shortly
let's just listen to a little of what he
said earlier it was insane
local officials and headquarters that it
was far
too dangerous to continue the mission
turn back
but they decided to continue anyway by
the way the audio guys the audio
knowing they might not return they knew
that people were engaged in great danger
as knight said they could see almost
nothing through the miles of dense smoke
using their night goggles and their
expert navigation skills they reached
the camp
they found the stranded families many of
whom were badly burned and injured
and they loaded them as many as they
could trump's trump's on speakerphone
then they made the perilous light back
to the base
as soon as they unloaded the passages
they again risked their lives
and flew back into the blazing fire to
rescue more victims
their superiors said you cannot do this
you cannot do it again
they did it the smoke had become even
more overpowering
yet they returned a third time it really
weaves quite a story huh let's skip
ahead this is just so low energy let's
see what else we've got
um here we go what else did he do
very strange stance there
okay so i think it's pretty clear that
the event earlier
um we probably got as much out of it as
we were going to get
so we are going to uh be standing by for
uh for the event um
pandering to latino voters at the top of
the hour
okay let's see here um
neon sm says with a twitch subscription
your previous chess opponent xqc with a
great message
uh it looks like you included a link
there
just for safety we have to uh block
those so i'm unsure
what what you wanted me to see also
thank you to stacks dc
stacks dc for the uh
twitch sub and thank you to audrey boone
who is new member number seven today at
joinpakman.com other super chats
are coming in uh or they're not no
wow no not and i don't have any
additional super chats to read
well if you want to send me a super chat
this would be a brilliant time
uh to get one read oh
kevin z says first super chat has
anthony mooch responded oh i'm in touch
with anthony scaramucci yeah
so i tweeted last week to scaramucci
that i want to have him on the show
and a mutual friend of ours got us in
touch
i spoke to scaramucci he said he has
agreed to an interview on the david
pakman show and
we are still figuring it out i am
looking forward to talking to scaramucci
about
does he have knowledge about trump upper
and downer use
what does he know about all of these
various
rumors about donald trump so i think
it's going to be
really really interesting to speak to
him phoenix 503
says i live in portland and the smoke is
so bad
some businesses could not open today
it's insane what is going on there
it is absolutely insane um
i have friends in portland and i've been
in touch with them and it is uh
absolutely outrageous absolutely
outrageous
um thank you to
amy mclaughlin as well as
kelly kasmar who were new members
eight and nine today at joinpakman.com
very much appreciate that also rafael
ware not sure how to pronounce that and
chris evola not ebola evola
is new member number 11 today at
joinedpakman.com
royal fino wants me to interview andrew
yang
again i would love to do it he has he
has basically
ghosted us uh we interviewed him three
times when he was less well known
and then he started ghosting us and
we've actually reached out
post primary and uh have not been able
to
uh get them on unfortunately so
if anybody wants to help with that one
we would be glad to this is sort of like
my dave rubin moment i'm like
i don't know we reached out to joe rogan
but it's kind of awkward but
you know that i'm kind of doing the same
thing with andrew yang but no he's not
um
he's not responding he's not i think
he's just he's too big now
for the david pakman show i think that's
the quite that's the reality
you know it's like a please clap moment
um
okay other super chats are starting to
come in
zesty says who do you think has done
more good for mexicans
cesar chavez or trump oh trump oh my god
trump's been the best for latino voters
he's been the best for the blacks as he
calls them
johann nilsson says congrats on a
million subscribers
cheers from a swedish fan thank you
johan
gina gonzalez says i'm so excited to see
you
i haven't been able to stomach trump
while you've been gone
congratulations on 1 million subs thank
you
alan canoni says what kind of ridiculous
statements can we plan on him making
oh that latino uh americans hispanic
americans
are doing better than ever under trump i
i assume that's the main point
lab lg says hello david a viewer from
france
congratulations on a million keep it up
daniel perkins asks why won't mainstream
dems
support universal basic income and a
green new deal
dems of the us would be considered
conservatives in much of europe yeah
uh the mainstream democratic party won't
support those things
because they don't support those things
it the the democratic party as we saw
during the primary is not nearly as left
as twitter and reddit would have us
believe
and that is reflected in many ways
including what you're pointing out
kant says congratulations on the one
million
has kyle from secular talk recorded a
message for you
he is not i reached out to kyle along
with uh
with everybody else who participated in
the video i did not hear back from kyle
so it's certainly possible the message
went to spam
uh or that he's been on vacation for a
couple of weeks or he didn't want to do
it i don't know
but i i did reach out to kyle i was
hoping to include him in the video and
i did not hear back bolo
turner oh i'm sorry no kyle hopper says
do you think trump will stand as weirdly
in spanish yeah i think trump's posture
is weird in any language
yeah jchat says what are your thoughts
on the kyle rittenhouse situation
i made a video on my channel about how
kyle was wrong and i seem to be getting
wrecked by both left and right
i have a bunch of clips about that
already so i don't want to redo my
commentary here
bolo turner says if y yang doesn't want
to come back on it's his loss
he ain't got a million subs on youtube
take that homie
it's not about that for me i would just
like to um i'd like to have him back on
because i think it'd be a fascinating
conversation
devin rockatansky says
my dad is super conservative what do i
do
uh you're gonna have to be a little more
specific what do you do in terms of
your relationship or what do you do in
terms of convincing him to change his
views
those are two very very different things
of course
let me say a few other thank yous
because i don't want to fall behind
spence banda is new member number 12.
pam longsha is new member number 13.
eseem akath is number 14
blake daly is number 15.
karen lebeau is new member number 16
and ashley guritz is new member number
17 today at joinedpakman.com
thanks very much i appreciate that um it
is
september on twitch i wish i knew what
it meant
i know that there are discounts involved
in september
is anybody able to tell me what it
actually is what it what it means
anybody know i think it's just discounts
it's sort of like the more you buy
the more you save sort of thing
discount okay good 30 off
new subs get a discount it's discounts
discounts okay very good 20 to 30
percent
nice 30
discount very good okay a few people
want more clips from trump's weird rally
yesterday
in uh nevada i'll look at a couple let's
see if we have them
uh actually i might have shown you all
the ones i have
let me check one of my other twitter
resources see if we have any more clips
from yesterday's
bizarre rally um
this is from earlier today trump gets
confused and says biden won a nobel
prize all right i want to hear that
they gave they nominated your president
twice last week on two different
subjects i read something about the
nominations were fraudulent
for nobel prize but
but the fake news media didn't cover it
so nothing
what
biden got it remember okay remember when
when uh our great president right barack
hussein obama
[Laughter]
our great president right trump loves
hispanics
hispanics are at 52 for trump and 40
something for that
[Applause]
they've never seen that before i love
the hispanics
he loves him okay here apparently trump
uh got a guy kicked out
yeah get him out of here would you
please
[Applause]
it's so funny because the crowd sort of
cheers because they're like yeah trump's
being tough
trump said get him out of here there's
like secret service and police and
security big tough trump is saying kick
him out
wow what a tough guy
[Applause]
okay hear trump talking about commas in
his new slogan
done now i say make america great again
again
comma
okay uh the crowd chanting for barack
obama to be locked up
uh is there anyone that shouldn't be
locked up in their mind
in the form of an ad from a third-rate
magazine whose best friend is obama
who by the way who by the way
who by the way got caught spying on my
campaign
he got caught we caught him cold we have
him call
now let's see what happens
[Applause]
i wish somebody could tell me what is
the crime trump says they caught him
red-handed
trump says it's the worst political
crime that's ever been con
uh uh committed and yet we still don't
know
what the crime actually is
um let's just do maybe one more here's
trump saying football's boring now i
guess because they kneel i don't know
football hold on it's boring as hell
the cr you can tell the crowd is
lukewarm on that this is
this is a sort of uh you know this is a
heartland crowd of sorts
and they're like wait i thought i was
supposed to like football football's
boring i don't know i mean i don't read
books
what what could be less books sound way
more boring than football to this crowd
[Applause]
it's just not the same right
used to be people say hey could you keep
it away from a football game now they
say
could you possibly do it during a
football game
we have some free time okay yeah so i
guess that that's trump uh
is complaining about sports or something
like that
very very weird stuff really involved in
a vote
in the u.s senate on a judge
confirmation so she did not travel but
as you saw in the earlier picture
oh okay here so trump landing now trump
actually landed now and we're starting
to get to uh
some of these important elements oh very
good okay let's see if i can find a
better stream now
trump live uh some of those some of
these fox affiliate streams are a little
dicey i don't exactly know what fox news
now is maybe it's okay
but um here's the latinos for fox
for trump roundtable on [ __ ] all right
so we got a couple different things but
trump landed now
and presumably we are getting closer and
closer
uh to hearing from him very very
important stuff okay
other super chats uh bronx
bjorn says i sent a message on another
stream about those trump emails
right on cue as poor management of
resources becomes public knowledge
they to my great annoyance double down
okay
um matt chavez says brian tyler cohen
has interviewed harris yang porter
schiff etc maybe reach out to him and
figure out who his rep is
uh the thing about brian is sort of like
he's in with the democratic party i'm
not even a democrat
so he's in a very different position
than i am as many of you know i am not i
am on the outside of the democratic
party not the inside
aaron cooper says i live in north
carolina and trump for some reason keeps
saying that the state is closed
everything's open except for a few clubs
and bars
yeah i mentioned that during his north
carolina speech last week
um trump keeps talking about the state
has to open open it up open up the
states like the state is open
just a lot of people are choosing not to
go out you can open a restaurant you
can't make people go
donald trump seems seems not to
understand that
um donna williams says
trump rallies remind me of a jerry
springer show and roller derbies
rolled into one agreed oh my god is the
latinos for trump event indoors
they're doing more of this indoor stuff
you've got to be out of your mind
to be doing that right now
what on earth are they doing
uh let's see if any of these other feeds
are live not yet okay
that's fine we'll stick with this one um
thanks to night coffee spudnik has just
gifted five subscriptions
on twitch and signed up uh
christopher is here has subscribed on
twitch
justin d winters is supporting on twitch
i appreciate it guys
very much appreciate it this event is in
phoenix
for people asking phoenix arizona
um oh i have a bunch of oh my goodness
i didn't even realize this i have so
many new members to thank hold on
spence ban okay no i already think
spence anthony d
pietri is new member number 18 vanessa
herdick is number 19.
james good is number 20. connie evers is
number 21.
jeff c is number 22. randy burton is
number 23
lena therese cetenoid is number 24.
bettina dransfeld is new member number
25
and david connors is new member number
26
uh you all know that when we get to 25 i
say let's go for 50. let's just do it
let's go for 50 and see if we can make
it um
jason nadal says you missed my chat okay
see if i can find it okay jason said
trump thinks reading military history
stories
and holding military ceremonies is
actually going to win veterans in active
duty votes
i'm a veteran and i can say it's not
working yeah i think calling
troops who died suckers and losers also
probably doesn't help that's my guess
a new amount says congratulations on 1
million subscribers
david just saw the tribute video well
deserved
thanks from australia
uh okay safanda boosh
says how can a clam cram in a clean
clean cream can that i'd have to ask a
scientist about sharpie diesel says is
anyone tracking whether or not these
rallies follow with an
outbreak of covid two weeks after the
events
uh yeah yes i mean so tulsa caused one
the sturgis motorcycle nonsense caused
one although that wasn't a trump event
officially
unofficially it sort of was
um let's see who else we've got here
hugh hundo says congrats my brother keep
up the quality and
insightful content you're one of my last
bastions of hope
for american civilization as we thank
you as we wait for donald trump
in phoenix arizona live on the left the
video on the right is earlier
um we will see uh how
gingerly donald trump walks off the
plane
today always a question you never know
could go uh any of any number of
directions as always with donald trump
he is expected to be pandering live to
latino voters hopefully my uh
internet connection will hold up i saw
we had a couple couple glitches there
hopefully it holds trans theories
asks how is the trump biden gap so close
uh i mean more than 60 million people in
this country
thought it made sense to vote for trump
last time we have a real problem in this
country
we have a problem with education we have
a problem with critical thinking
we have a problem with media literacy we
have we have major problems here anybody
who tells you otherwise is either lying
or not paying its attention
um okay
let's see here uh are we having
buffering
are we are we having a buffering issue
can anybody tell me because i am getting
messages about buffering
we want to try to avoid buffering
buffering is not so good
dropping frames yeah i was worried about
that
my connection is good but it's not
pristine it's not pristine today
yeah we'll do the best we can
we'll do the best we can um
let's see here austin smith says via
super chat
imagine visiting the site of the largest
forest fires in history and
saying temperatures will get cooler and
i don't
think science knows so dismissive of
americans
struggling on his watch yeah
presumptuous
pompous arrogant delusional ignorant
you know all of the things that donald
trump is uh is known for essentially
jeffrey geltman says in the new marvel
adventure avengers video game
plasma is a resource do you think trump
should announce that this video game
could cure covet sure why not
eton beaver being careful there eton
baber
says a census taker once tried to test
me
i ate his liver with fava beans and a
chianti that's weird
carlos murphy says can you please read
my super chat i thought i did
let's see if i can find it
carlos murphy okay carlos murphy said
like trump doesn't biden have a silent
supporter
that aren't pole could the polls be way
off in the other direction
congratulations on hitting a million
there is really no evidence of a
significant
shy voting uh electorate there's a bunch
of
of good articles about this um our
friend bill share has posted about it
there is really not
anything empirical
that we've been able to find indicating
that there are so-called
shy voters for either candidate in any
sort of significant amount
um okay we continue
okay here comes donald trump let's see
where he's going let's see if he finds
his way to his car
as some of you know donald trump
sometimes
gets off the plane and even though the
car is right in front of him he has
wandered
off before and secret service sort of
has to grab him and bring him back
let's take a look let's get live audio
of what's going on
and uh the president continuing what has
been
quite a day already and he will not
arrive back at the white house
until 11 30 tonight on the south lawn
of marine one that'll be 11 30 eastern
9 30 our time salute and should greet
the governor there with the mask on this
is kind of typical the people who greet
the president have to wear the mask the
president
chooses not to chooses
all right
okay hard to imagine what uh what that
conversation is like of course
um and standing by for the actual event
with donald trump
um pandering to latino voters that's
what's on the schedule today
so does the governor just greet trump
and then they go in separate vehicles
that's kind of awkward isn't it
huh that actually seemed a little tense
i don't know that was weird
not seeing the uh smiling that you
typically see during the greeting
moments
oh my god look there are they doing it
are they having to pull trump back
oh no trump i guess he's going over to
talk to some people
see if we do we have any live audio here
talking to reporters i guess let's say
welcome back to arizona
this is a great way to kick off hispanic
heritage
month a lot of good things happening in
our state
and we're grateful for your support of
us during coping 19
the personal protective equipment the
surge testing to
maryvale and phoenix and of course
usmcas
allowed us to navigate through this with
one of the best economies
save the pandemic with our number one
trade partner in mexico
but you know doug did a great job in
arizona where
the number went high quickly and then
you just bumped you went down
you were tough he was strong and he did
the right thing and the numbers went
down we had a big victory just now in
pennsylvania
i don't know if you heard about it they
were ordered to open it up a federal
judge
and open it up and let the people uh
get back to work let's see if that's
true that's what you've done and you've
done a great job
thank you very much
hispanic with the hispanic vote and
very honored by it we're very honored by
those calls so we'll see you over there
thank you
thank you what's your message to arizona
we are working with your governor it's a
great governor and we're uh
i think doing a really good job for
hispanics
we're doing a fantastic job and i think
it really
uh is represented very well in the
polling numbers that we're getting
because
they haven't really seen numbers like
that for a long time so we're very very
honored but thank you
thank you very much
okay president trump will hit the
motorcade heading out to arizona grand
resort and spa
he is running a little late the
president uh kind of is a punctuality
guy
but what what puncture what station is
this what what's fox affiliate is this
trump's late to everything he does a
punctuality guy i don't even understand
what that means that's insane
uh okay so anyway trump they're speaking
about the spanish
and the hispanics i guess he's in favor
of both from what i understand
gregory shavers jr says this year's
hurricane season
is insane yes it is milo
aveels says thou shalt not muzzle the ox
when he treadeth out the corn
i don't know the relevance to
this particular event but uh
that that may well be accurate yes
um the wilhelm screen has subscribed for
10 months on twitch and says hey david
also a website member hope everyone
remembers to like and
subscribe follow congratulations
on one million subscribers
on youtube yes indeed yes indeed and we
are actually now
at one million four thousand on youtube
one million four thousand very very
important
and lastly thanks to timothy woodard
timothy woodard
is new member number 27 today at
joinedpakman.com
very much appreciated as we are down to
the last
oh 15 or so minutes before the start of
donald trump's event pandering to latino
voters
the motorcade there in phoenix heading
from the airport to
what we believe is an indoor event